[Music]
baking is my communication tool with
american people
i'm not so good speak english but i can
make in a good dessert so during a
holiday i always making a japanese
christmas shortcake
i'm niko tortorella i'm an actor an
activist and a firm believer that our
differences actually make us stronger
i'm on a journey with ikea to meet real
people and discover the diverse and
spectacular ways they celebrate the
holidays
[Music]
maybe you celebrate christmas with milk
and cookies and a christmas ham or maybe
you celebrate it with fried chicken and
cake like portland resident mio asaka my
name is mio asaka
i'm a baker and owner of meals
delectables
mio runs a mini japanese bakery right
out of her own home and sells her goods
at the portland farmers market mio has
this real passion for baking and sharing
the traditions that she brought from
japan her specialty the japanese
christmas cake
[Music]
we should probably go get some
strawberries for this yeah
wow
mio's delectables isn't just a business
for mio it's a way for her to share her
traditions and culture with other people
and to really bring people together
especially during the holidays
oh wow my christmas tree is like a
different size of tree
but i always decoration you have to
enjoy that this is your son here
yes
willie william williams
i admire mio for being a single mother
who works hard to create a warm inviting
and loving home for her family
[Music]
japanese christmas is pretty unique for
a while it was a really romantic holiday
in japan kind of like valentine's day in
the united states
romance
fried chicken is really popular
and dessert
christmas cake especially is a focal
point for japanese christmas
[Music]
when i came to the us i didn't know that
this country not familiar with japanese
style type of the cake so i explained
this cake is very soft and not too sweet
now it's a very popular this looks so
beautiful japanese christmas cake
originated in post-world war ii japan
middle-class citizens finally had access
to sugar and other ingredients that had
once been considered exclusive and from
this the tradition was born all right
it's time to eat
japanese christmas
is a important day we eat a big dinner
with our family
it's very much like the u.s but we eat
sushi and karage
do you have any traditions before a
christmas meal
we said itadakimasu
bon appetit
[Music]
mio is pretty inspiring she truly
embodies the tradition represented by
something as simple as a cake
japanese christmas cake is a symbol for
prosperity and growth
qualities that mio really brings to life
every time she bakes this cake for her
friends and family
[Music]
there you have it folks rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer